so I've always been interested in
chemistry at low temperature cooling
things right down to see what happens so
I think I'm good to try it out on my
pumpkin first of all just to jazz it up
I'm going to light up the pumpkin so
here we are these stakes themselves are
chemically quite interesting when you do
the reaction you make molecules in an
excited state and they give out light so
let's let's be a bit greedy and useful
so now I'm going to start cooling it
down so because liquid nitrogen that I'm
going to use to cool it is quite cold
and you can burn yourself I've got my
gloves on
so let's get going so the nitrogen is
it's going in is that nearly minus 200
degrees centigrade it cools everything
down and it's cooled down the light
stick so the light sticks are now gone
out completely because the chemical
reactions have slowed down so much that
they've really stopped so it's going to
take a lot of liquid nitrogen to cool
this down but it's crackling nicely it's
sprung a small leak around this side but
let's hope it's not too bad I think we
cut it a bit too much when we were
carving it out in new go so the holes
got a bit bigger so I put it on its side
liquid nitrogen is quite light it's much
lighter than water so but we must be
patient let it cool down a bit so what's
happening when we cool it down is that
the water in the pumpkin is freezing
solid to make ice and when it's solid it
gets much more brittle so all being well
then when we hit it it's going to go
into lots of little pieces
where I need to take aim so that was not
bad was it so I think I didn't do badly
you see what the others can do
for the Halloween special of periodic
table videos check out my pumpkin I
carved it myself I quite liked the
design what we're going to do is
introduce the the magic flammable
substance which is actually a gel made
of calcium acetate and an alcohol
ethanol
let's slop it in yeah good coating in
there of the gel and I've just realized
as I don't got lighter once it's going
so let's let's let's make sure we get
this from by going first of all oh yes
so where's the light sorry
there we go so we've got orange flame
and we're going to see what happens when
we add this substance to it which when I
take the lid off you'll see it's a very
nice vibrant blue color okay but those
of you who've done your chemistry we've
got copper so let's see what color it
should give us there we go what you're
getting is the green color in the flames
from the copper oh that's some of the
gel at the top oh that's awesome I
didn't realize it was it looks like it's
being sick rhenium so what we've got
here
strontium nitrate those have you done
your chemistry we'll know what strontium
color will give us so here is white kind
of powdery substance quite boring but
watch what happens when we put it in
we've got the green now I adding red to
mix the pumpkins still cold on the
outside so you know I can touch it
absolutely fine no problem
while these pumpkins on fire
Halloween Canales has a pumpkin pie many
people have said are we going to play
with liquid oxygen but Neil and I had a
bit of a chinwag and we decided that
that was far too obvious
so we've gone for another one of our
favorites which Neil has got in his hand
which is a small charge of thermite
thanks it's good enough yeah is it good
for light yep we might make some like a
minute
so thermite is a mixture of aluminium
and iron oxide and again it's a
classical competition reaction where
they're competing for the oxygen
aluminium is going to win because it's
much more reactive and it's going to
make molten hot iron which we hope is
going to total our pumpkin so pumpkin
thermite sparkler fire yeah okay
pumpkin soup
Wow I think our pumpkins been sick
molten iron
how cool look at that what do you say to
the other pumpkin people in competition
hanging on time again next year
come along Martin when you think you're
Arden up with anyone for roast pumpkin